bonjour à tous je vous présente la
journée catamaran de la fpc
bonne journée à tous voilà un accueil
très chaleureux à la hauteur de la
journée qui attend les résidents de
l'association des familles de
traumatisés crâniens de la martinique
sept victimes d'accidents de la route
qu'ils en gardent de graves séquelles
ont pris la mer pour assister à la
deuxième étape du tour des yoles à bord
de catamarans
parmi eux jean claude et joël ils sont
aux anges
ils ne veulent rien rater du spectacle
sur l'eau
[Musique]
adium amérindiens singer un but je suis
enchantée à chevrier ce cas et puis je
vois porridge désigner son père c'est
traumatisés crâniens sont accompagnés de
tout un staff infirmières et aboutira
peut tu aides soignants et anthony ça
leur permet de s'évader de sortiront un
peu de voir ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur parce que vraiment il ya des
résidents qui dont les parents ne
peuvent pas répondre tous les week-ends
donc c'est très important pro de voir ce
qui se passe aux alentours
surtout quand ils entendent taux de viol
noël carnaval enfin être schizophrène
cette sortie en mer est organisé depuis
douze ans par l'association madinina 10
qui mène plusieurs actions d'ordre
social il n'aura semaine et nous retrace
maintenant à moi l'art sourire c'est ça
notre récompense tout le travail que
nous accomplissons c'est cela notre
récompense donnée voit aussi heureux
d'être avec les valides
parce qu'ils étaient valides et les
accidents de la vie ont fait que
maintenant ils sont appelés personnes
personnes à mobilité réduite donc il
faut qu on les élit faut qu'il soit avec
nous je trouve que pour nous c'est
primordial sont pas les oublier une
journée mémorable pour ces patients qui
ont été futé pour l'anecdote jean claude
izzo elle supporte la yole ufr chanflor